The father is beginning to slip mentally with memory and cognitive function.
What was your recommended supplement wise?
I've had research in a D.
What is the best if you had to pick one?
Well, usually with early dementia, Alzheimer's, any type of memory loss,
you just ran across for there's inflammation in the brain.
Now, you could have graduated with people
with what's causing that inflammation because the truth is a lot of things can cause that inflammation.
It's why very much it gets the flu vaccine or elderly,
they push it so hard, elderly,
has way too many micrograms of aluminum in it.
And the size of aluminum is, you know, they say it's really small,
so you don't have to worry about it.
Well, you have to worry about it even more because it's really small.
It easily crosses the blood brain barrier and it's the source of inflammation.
All the studies out there on Alzheimer's,
a brain inflammation, microglyoprime, antibodies to neural tissue,
tie to infection and toxins, also possible injury like post-concussive syndrome.
So people that have had concussions through their life are going to be much more prone to microglyoprime,
which leads to, depending on where it is, which can lead to dementia and loss of brain function or Parkinson's
or full blood Alzheimer's disease.
So I have a video on this on our website.
It's called Neural Inflammation and Microglyoprime.
So on the website, if you search Neural Inflammation, you'll see that.
But it goes into depth about that and it goes into depth about what supplements to use.
In general, the supplements that you would want to use would be anti-inflammatories.
So would you take this person to try to do chelation therapy to pull out the heavy metals
if this person has heavy metal issues?
Well, personally, I wouldn't do that unless we did a full workup and figured out what could be the cause,
so we don't look what we're dealing with.
But in general, you'd want to decrease the inflammation.
So the way you would decrease inflammation is using flavonoids.
What are flavonoids?
There are supplements like Kerkimid, I mentioned before,
rosemary, porcetin, baswellia.
We have a product that has a bunch of them.
It is called Clear Inflamm.
There's another product called caparrests that has a bunch of them in there.
We use both of those a lot.
But taking a bunch of flavonoids and getting on an anti-inflammatory diet is the key.
Also, I'd say you've got, I don't know if your dad's a drinker,
if he likes his beer or he likes his hot toddy at night,
alcohol is the worst culprit with all the research, great inflammation.
He's got to get off alcohol.
And then other things that are common that can cause more inflammation.
Gluten is a key factor.
Look at other food sensitivities.
But never what is getting on flavonoids.
I haven't taken a lot of flavonoids.